[Música]
aquí comienza el debate de France 24 Mi
nombre es Ángela Gómez Y los acompaño en
este programa para hablar en el cierre
de los días de luto tras el
fallecimiento de la Reina Isabel II del
Reino Unido así terminó la segunda era
de isabelina una de las más notables en
la historia de la nación con 70 años en
la jefatura de estado y una influencia
que fue sinónimo de estabilidad durante
las décadas transcurridas para conversar
sobre este tema nos acompañan dativos
salvia historiador especializado en
casas reales desde Barcelona España y
también está con nosotros Soy Carmen
duerto periodista y escritora sobre la
realeza además autora del libro Leticia
una mujer real y biógrafa de la infanta
Elena de Borbón gracias a ambos y a
nuestros televidentes también les
recuerdo que hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en Twitter Instagram y Facebook
donde no se encuentran como @france24
trabajo es y arroba Ángela gof24 mi
cuenta personal la etiqueta es el
numeral el debate f24 además en YouTube
ustedes pueden Seguir nuestra señal en
streaming también saludamos a las
personas que nos escuchan en nuestro
podcast no olviden que todos los
contenidos de nuestro programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast Spotify
deezer y tuning para entrar en materia
veamos un resumen de estos últimos actos
de despedida de Isabel segunda desde las
11 de la mañana hora local empezó un
evento en donde alrededor de 500 jefes
de estado de gobierno y diplomáticos
estuvieron invitados miles de personas
pasaron la noche del domingo en la calle
de Londres Para ocupar los mejores
puestos en el acto fúnebre uno que
estuvo cargado de significado y de
simbolismo el informe es de Juan Pablo
lukumi
fue el último adiós a la reina después
de cuatro días en los que miles de
personas pasaron frente al ataúd de
Isabel II en la parte más antigua del
parlamento británico el féretro de la
monarca fue transportado por 142 Marines
hacia la abadía de Westminster mientras
detrás caminaba en el Rey Carlos III y
sus hermanos La princesa Ana y Los
Príncipes Andrés y Eduardo también fue
escoltado por William y Harry nietos de
Isabel II
[Música]
la ceremonia fúnebre la primera de un
monarca británico en ser transmitida se
consagró como el primer funeral de
estado desde el de Winston Churchill en
Su difunta Majestad declararon una
transmisión de su cumpleaños 21 que se
dedicaría a toda su vida a servir a la
nación y a la mancomunidad de Naciones
rara vez se ha cumplido también una
promesa así cerca de 500 de los 2000
invitados eran líderes internacionales
los ex primeros ministros de Reino Unido
David Cameron Teresa May Boris Johnson y
la actual Premier también estuvieron
presentes la ceremonia de un poco más de
50 minutos tuvo lecturas y cánticos
religiosos y se escuchó el himno Dios
salve al rey recién modificado para el
nuevo monarca Carlos III
[Música]
Poco después los restos de la Reina
Isabel pasaron en una histórica
procesión por las calles del centro de
Londres hacia el arco de Wellington muy
cercano al palacio de buckingham más de
6000 soldados participaron en el
recorrido una vez en el coche fúnebre el
ataúd tomó rumbo a la capilla de San
George en el castillo de Windsor A las
afueras de Londres lugar donde cerca de
800 personas presentaron por última
ocasión sus respetos a Isabel II allí
finalmente la monarca más longeva de
Reino Unido descansará junto a la tumba
de su padre el rey Jorge vi Isabel la
reina madre y su esposo Felipe El Duque
de edimburgo
y quiero comenzar las preguntas con
dativo salvia dativo con este funeral
real se cierra una etapa que es sin duda
muy importante para la monarquía del
Reino Unido en qué condiciones deja
Isabel segunda la jefatura de estado que
ahora hereda Carlos III
es una es una pregunta que todos se
están haciendo todos nos estamos
haciendo es complicado
en el Reino Unido las diversas naciones
que Lo componen han Jurado lealtad al
nuevo rey pero no hay que olvidar que en
Escocia hay planteado sin fecha un
referéndum de Independencia lo que
ocurre que en Escocia
aceptan aceptarían a Carlos como rey si
en el referéndum saliera Independencia
en los otros en las otras naciones la
cuestión no es tan peligrosa como en
gales Aunque en Irlanda del Norte
también hay un movimiento importante de
personas que quieren unirse y de
partidos políticos que ahora mismo en el
gobierno autónomo de Irlanda del Norte
tienen mayoría que quisieran unirse a la
República de Irlanda eso en el Reino
Unido y en el extranjero los 14 reinos
de los cuales Carlos III es soberano ya
en este momento algunos de ellos algunos
caribeños están planteándose también el
organizar referéndums para si se
continúa teniendo un jefe de estado Que
es el rey del Reino Unido de La Gran
Bretaña o se pasa a una República en
Australia Canadá y Nueva Zelanda Parece
que la cosa no avanzará de esa manera de
momento Carlos creo que tiene ese reto
ante sí como como primer gran reto
porque en el resto de las cuestiones
internas él seguirá la línea de su madre
Esa es mi opinión muy bien y ahora
Carmen Un saludo para ustedes y le hago
la misma pregunta En qué estado queda la
jefatura del estado o la monarquía
después del fallecimiento de Isabel
segunda más ahora que hereda Carlos III
un país que está dividido por aspectos
como los que mencionaba dativo
Pues yo creo que lo tiene muy difícil va
a ser un reinado muy complicado no tan
largo por supuesto como el de la madre
Es evidente y tiene un enorme problema
cuando Isabel llega al Trono es muy
joven no tiene pasado Tiene dos niños
pequeños y simpática Y eso obra a su
favor los medios de comunicación también
son muy limitados la opinión pública muy
controlada y el país que hereda ahora
bueno el trono que hereda ahora Carlos
es completamente distinto las
circunstancias son diferentes Él lleva
70 años manifestando su opinión y no
siempre del agrado del pueblo inglés ni
de los extranjeros entonces a nosotros
por ejemplo en España no nos agradó nada
que su luna de miel empezará en
Gibraltar que quiero recordar que es la
única Colonia que existe en territorio
europeo y la tienen los ingleses
Entonces eso de vez en cuando a nosotros
nos tocan un poquito así como nos hacen
aquí en España hay una expresión que
dicen tus narices Bueno pues los
ingleses en eso suelen hacerlo con
Gibraltar entonces
Carlos hereda un país complicado que ya
digo que sus manifestaciones públicas y
privadas porque se le han interceptado
conversaciones como todo el mundo sabe
pues no han sido del agrado ni de sus
súbditos ni de los extranjeros entonces
la opinión pública es muy potente porque
existen las redes sociales con lo cual
la soberanos que es la gente el pueblo
pues manifiesta su opinión y no es una
persona excesivamente empática esa forma
que ha tenido de iniciar su reinado con
unas muestras muy déspotas y un
comportamiento hacia el servicio pues
que no ha sido Del agrado Pues también
ya empieza diciendo mucho de esta
persona muy bien Vamos a seguir por esa
línea dativo le voy a pedir porque
justamente en las apariciones públicas
se ha podido ver un Carlos tercero muy
cercano a la gente y sin embargo también
ha recibido muchas críticas porque
estos gestos que ha tenido con sus
empleados han sido muy criticables en
palacio aquellos episodios de la firma
de documentos y los malos gestos que
quedaron grabados en cámara por supuesto
además de denuncias de vestidos
relacionados con su ascenso al Trono y
pues dejar su condición de Príncipe así
que bueno mi pregunta para ustedes cómo
es la imagen del nuevo monarca en este
en este inicio de una nueva etapa y
después de un cambio de Mando que es
histórico para la nación
sí como como decía Carmen Hay ciertos
aspectos Que que
Carlos viene de 70 años de muchos años
de 70 años de ser heredero de ser
príncipe de gales y manifestando sus
opiniones de manera muy libre cosa que
él ha dicho que se acabó porque
obviamente su papel ahora es de Rey
constitucional y no emitirá las
opiniones que gustaban a unos y no
gustaban a otros pero muchas de sus
opiniones sí gustaban a mucha gente él
es uno de los iniciadores del movimiento
ecologista en el mundo ya en los años 70
cosa que otras personas No tenían idea
en esos momentos de lo que quería decir
no del de la protección del medio
ambiente etcétera
respecto a otras cuestiones tiene una
asociación complicada como decía como
decía Carmen
no lo tienen fácil él la manera que se
ha mostrado estos días es muy empática y
es así él realmente y yo creo que esos
ge que se han hecho virales son gestos
de una persona de 73 años al cual se ha
muerto su Ha fallecido su madre y que
estaba sometido les decía tres días a un
continuo ir y venir por las diversas
naciones del Reino Unido pues recibiendo
obviamente la lealtad de los parlamentos
ceremonia religiosas etcétera etcétera
para mí no tienen más importancia que
eso por momento de nervios de que las
cosas no salen bien en un momento
determinado pero yo me quedo con la
manera de de Carlos de saludar a la
gente de su empatía Y de lo que dicen
muchos testimonios que lo han conocido
muy bien o lo conocen muy bien de su
enorme sensibilidad por muchas cosas por
muchas cuestiones que atañen a la gente
y al mundo Bueno claro y no podemos
dejar de tener en cuenta que es un
hombre de avanzada edad que está
viajando por todo el Reino Unido en un
ambiente de absoluta atención y que hace
que se cuestionen algunos la estabilidad
en el país después del cambio de Mando y
ahora Quisiera seguir con nuestra
invitada para preguntarle por esas
mismas opiniones porque dativo dice que
seguramente ya como rey no lo vamos a
escuchar pronunciarse tan abiertamente
como lo hizo en su momento de príncipe y
y usted cree eso que las opiniones
ambientales de migración de Carlos
desaparecerán como rey que ya nos
expresará de la misma manera que lo hizo
como príncipe claro eso Es evidente él
lo ha dicho que se acabó dar opiniones y
de hecho es que los reyes no opinan
Ellos están en la en la puntita de la
pirámide están allá arriba y otean no
pero ni manifiestan ni por aquí ni por
allá entonces por eso es por lo que esta
reina ha tenido 15 primeros ministros me
parece de cualquier ideología Esta
última republicana Sería más lejos y
Bueno hasta no le ha dado tiempo a
tratarla Pero ha seguido ella allí
Carlos ha sido más difícil porque claro
estar 70 años callados es muy complicado
Cuando él daba sus opiniones alegremente
y ya digo que no del gusto de todos
entonces eso se recuerda también Es
verdad que estos momentos empáticos que
está teniendo saludando a la gente que
eso crea mucho vínculo pues está muy
bien y esto es lo aprendió esta
monarquía cuando con Diana de gales
Diana de gales se llevaba la gente de
calle era la princesa del pueblo y ahí
ellos se dieron cuenta del valor que
tenía acercarse al pueblo y tener esos
gestos el llevar por ejemplo hoy a los
niños a los bisnietos a los bisnietos de
la reina pues es un detalle como un
humano familiar son los nietos del
actual Rey los niños lloran Pues eso
crea más vínculo saludar dar la mano
Pues también acerca Yo he estado en
Windsor y en buckingham varias veces y
además concretamente con con Carlos
Carlos si se te acerca te da la mano no
hay ningún problema Incluso te hace
bromas ese famoso humor inglés puedes
hablar con él de Ecología de jardinería
a mí me encanta la jardinería y yo he
estado hablando de High Grove que fue
una obra personal suya luego él vende
sus mermeladas sus galletas su vino todo
ecológico y tal esto pues va a tener que
pasarse pasarle el testigo igual que las
400 organizaciones en las que él era
presidente pues las tendrá que pasar a
su a su heredero al príncipe de gales y
él ya dejará de dar opiniones
evidentemente tendrá que ser empático
aunque a veces pues le moleste o se lave
las manos 14 veces pero no le queda otra
ahora es rey ahora le toca a él él
su reinado claro está muy condicionado
por tan larguísimo que ha sido el de la
madre y tanta Espera que ha tenido él no
que cuando la gente se jubila Pues él es
cuando va a empezar a trabajar pero es
que no lo hiciera eh que estaba antes
delegado por la madre pero bueno ahora
es cuando le toca
su trabajo de verdad ser rey y por
supuesto que tomará medidas porque no le
queda otra y porque cada uno Quiero
poner su impronta cada uno quiere pasar
a la historia con algún motivo él tiene
el de la arquitectura el de la ecología
de los alimentos orgánicos también la
medicina natural pues Oye a lo mejor
tenemos un rey macrobiótico o
vegetariano pues fenomenal no Claro De
todas maneras Lo cierto es que pasa a
ser figuras central y dativo ustedes ya
estuvo como invitado en Francia 24
durante todo este proceso que ha sido la
despedida de la Reina Isabel segunda y
quiero pedirle que hablemos sobre la
importancia de la monarquía y de Isabel
segunda propiamente como esta monarca
que representó en arboló una figura de
estabilidad y que ayudó a definir el
futuro de la nación durante su
larguísimo su papel lo decía bien
nuestra invitada le impedía acciones
políticas al menos de manera directa no
opinan en público nunca conoceremos
digamos en medios de comunicación lo que
opina un rey o una reina sin embargo las
reuniones semanales de la Reina Isabel
segunda con sus primeros ministros y que
fueron hartos se influenciaron
decisiones posteriores sin influenciaron
el destino de la nación o Usted qué
opina Cuáles serían los ejemplos más
notables de ello
sin duda las aunque no haya trascendido
sí que ha trascendido algunas cositas de
memorias de antiguos primeros ministros
o de ministros en el en los en las que
pues comentaban el la influencia que la
reina tenía
estos días se habla mucho de poder suave
del soft Power que la reina ejerció
durante esos 70 años influyendo en los
primeros ministros en muchos momentos
delicados
la crisis de suez no cuando los
británicos pierden suez
el gobierno de Isabel II quería Iniciar
una guerra con Egipto en los años esos
los años 50 los primeros años de su
reinado se dice que fue la Reina Isabel
la que empeoró un poquito esos ánimos
belicosos de su gobierno
en la época de madre cuando las medidas
que toda la cama Wells y buena parte de
la comunidad internacional tomó contra
Sudáfrica contra el gobierno blanco de
en África Defensores de lapad height
Margarita Sánchez no quiso
unirse a esas medidas a ese boicot
contra Sudáfrica la Reina Isabel hizo
costado se alió con nosotros primeros
ministros de la common Wells para que la
common Wells en conjunto
impusiera sanciones al gobierno blanco
que que protegía la Pathfinder
es ha sido su tónica influir de manera
discreta de manera
inteligente
esa ha sido su labor con los primeros
ministros con el mundo político y no
solo con los primeros ministros
británicos también con nosotros primeros
ministros de la commonwealth muy bien y
Carmen usted como evalúa esta influencia
evidente pero no propiamente oficial de
la monarca durante todos estos años y
esa figura de estabilidad que se nos fue
que nos deja un Carlos III que usted ya
muy bien describió de avanzada edad y
que va a tener dificultades diferentes a
los del tiempo que inició el reinado de
Isabel segunda
vamos a ver una mujer que ha recibido
aquí a 15 primeros ministros de su país
ha tenido Supongo que una influencia en
ellos una influencia sutil que es como
tienen que ser los reyes sutil como
decir pero sin decir y ya uno lo recoge
y yo creo que el que fue fantástico fue
Churchill yo creo que eso para ella fue
fundamental no el trono y tener
esa estratega eso le dio una perspectiva
a ella y una sagacidad que espero que la
pusiera en marcha con el resto de
primeros ministros luego hay una pena y
esto mi compañero de debatelo lo
reconocerá pero vaya al pie de la letra
que es la rabia que da que esta mujer
llevaba un diario todos los días
escribía las cosas que ocurrían y sus
pensamientos o las reuniones que tenía
con gente de todos los
aspectos y no lo podremos leer hasta
dentro de 75 años eso sí que es una
faena sé que la perspectiva de una
historiador es muy larga pero es una
rabia porque ahora es cuando te surgen
los problemas las dudas las preguntas
ahora es cuando nos encantaría leer ese
cuaderno de la Reina Isabel que la
acabamos de enterrar Hace unas horas y
haber conocido muchos aspectos que
además influyen en el resto de del mundo
porque Inglaterra ha sido un país
protagonista en muchas en muchas cuitas
internacionales con lo cual hubiera sido
muy interesante descubrir y leer esos
diarios pero ahora esta tarde Que
supongo que su hijo Los estará leyendo
ávidamente para aprender
muy bien y dativo usted tiene alguna
opinión sobre estas memorias que por lo
que dicen Pues ni siquiera estaremos
vivos nosotros para para enterarnos
estoy Completamente de acuerdo con
Carmen sería interesantísimo poderlas
leer poder conocer lo que opinaba la
reina sobre todas las personas que
pasaron por su vida que no solo son esos
15 sino son
cientos de políticos de en primer lugar
de la common Bueno pero luego de todos
los países del mundo que iban a
visitarla los presidentes de Estados
Unidos los papás de Roma los otros Reyes
La la relación íntima que ha tenido con
la casa real Española y con otras casas
reales los consejos que le dio a Don
Juan Carlos cuando Don Juan Carlos
empezaba su reinado en el año 75 Y eso
se sabe que es que que ocurrió
han salido algunas cositas como he dicho
antes en Memorias de políticos
diplomáticos y ministros de sus
gobiernos o que han estado cercanos a
ella pero pero Son poquitas cosas no no
llegarán nunca a ser esos diarios que
verán nuestros hijos o nietos si es que
no son recortados como hicieron con los
diarios de la reina Victoria que fueron
recortados por su hija Beatriz la abuela
de Don Juan Carlos que no quería que
salieran en las en la publicación de sus
días de los diarios de su madre cosas
que no gustaban a la familia
bien y hay otro tema y aquí pues voy a
entrar en digamos en un terreno
desagradable para la monarquía y es el
último gran escándalo con las denuncias
de Meghan markle de racismo en la casa
real y esto nunca fue confirmado pero
pero sí se especuló muchísimo en los
medios de comunicación sobre quién era
el responsable de estos comentarios
supuestamente racistas contra el hijo o
los hijos de Meghan markle uno de esos
sospechosos que señala la prensa es
precisamente el hoy Rey Carlos III y se
sabe que las relaciones entre el
príncipe Harry y su padre pues son muy
distantes así mismo con el resto de la
casa real Así que aquí Mi pregunta es si
habrá lugar para que Carlos III digamos
tome este asunto en riendas y pueda
haber alguna manera de reparación o
simplemente la monarquía guardará
silencio lejano como lo ha hecho con
tantos otros escándalos
Yo pienso que Meghan markel miente como
una posesa en en ese aspecto dentro de
la familia real británico No creo que
exista el racismo sí que lo hay en la
sociedad británica Y eso es obvio porque
en artículos de diario o en opinadores
dentro de la prensa amarilla de la
prensa Escandalosa inglesa ha habido
comentarios racistas obvios y evidentes
por parte de la familia y yo no me lo
creo para nada Y menos del Rey la
familia real británica el Rey Carlos y
la Reina Isabel
llevan toda su vida teniendo relación
cercana con muchísimas personas de todas
las etnias de todas las de todas las
confesiones
No creo para nada lo que lo que ha dicho
Megan y creo que es un elemento de
publicidad para ella para sus futuras
memorias series documentales o las
diversas cuestiones que ya realiza para
ganarse el sueldo Carmen su opinión Yo
no sería tan crítica y no pondría toda
la carne en el asador contra Megan
primero porque uno no sabe lo que los
sentimientos que se generan con
determinadas uno cuando es blanco pues
no tiene esa sensibilidad cuando le
dicen a lo mejor algo por el color
porque Bueno pues es que unos blancos
pues no tiene ese problema alguien que
es mestizo Es más sutil a alguien que es
más que es mestizo Es más sensible a las
cosas que se dicen en ese sentido el
Duque de edimburgo El marido de la Reina
Isabel era muy metepatas solía meter la
pata en este sentido amparándose en el
humor inglés y que soy el marido de la
reina pues te soltaba una barbaridad el
Rey Carlos
bueno sin Megan ha tenido esa sensación
yo lo pongo en duda y quiero tener un
voto de confianza hacia Megan más de
poder de que le sirva esto para
promocionarse Megan no es la mala de la
película su marido se llama Harry su
marido es el que se ha educado en esa
cultura en esa familia y en esas
circunstancias es el que ha vivido en un
palacio Megan no Megan no arrastra a su
marido a que salga de ese lugar si él
ha decidido ambos tomar esa decisión es
porque ha sido algo mayor no ha sido una
pataleta creo que
A lo mejor era simplemente una sensación
Pero ha debido de ser algo mayor Porque
alguien que renuncia a su título de
alteza Real que renuncia a su seguridad
que renuncie a sus Palacios que renuncia
luego bien que se vive allí siendo
miembro de la familia real inglesa Pues
yo creo que se lo tiene que pensar
muchísimo que es que debe de ser algo
más fuerte más que por aumentar sus
contratos Megan y también me he acordado
estos días muchísimo de la pargey me he
acordado muchísimo estos días de Nelson
Mandela me acordaba muchísimo
estos días de la India y del gueto que
en el que vivían los ingleses los
blancos en ese país el cisma que se
organizó con Pakistán O sea que me he
acordado mucho estos días la reina no
sería racista la reina querría todo el
mundo pero la historia en ese sentido no
le no les avala Y si miran que ha sido
el último elemento perturbador en entrar
en esa familia que es Mestiza y sus
hijos también pues ha sentido eso
quiero pensar que es algo más que una
pataleta
pasando a otros temas digamos que
también podrían ser de interés público
el gasto para las despedidas que sean
efectuado para la Reina Isabel podemos
deducir apenas que ha sido un gasto
millonario Mientras que el país recibe
registra al mismo tiempo cifras récord
de inflación en medio de la crisis de
suministros desatada por la Guerra de
Ucrania en Aquí les quiero preguntar a
ustedes y comenzaría con Carmen es si es
criticable el gasto que se ha llevado a
cabo para todas estas honras que hemos
visto durante más de una semana pues en
honor a la Reina Isabel y para hacernos
una idea hace 25 años en los funerales
de Lady costaron probablemente más de 5
millones de euros Así que si traemos esa
cifra el día de hoy pues es mucho dinero
a ver ese que es muy populista decir
esto no vamos a ver estamos despidiendo
a una reina que es todo un símbolo es la
gran y de todo el mundo O sea la
abuelita de todo y la llaman de Queen
como como la reina de todos ellos tienen
una pompa y circunstancia y tienen todas
estas cosas de su protocolo inglés y sus
cosas establecida y ellos son así tienen
las carrozas las plumas todo esto que
estamos viendo las coronas y es su hotel
ellos también esto luego lo rentabilizan
luego venden muchísimos Souvenir uno va
a Windsor y tienen una tienda oficial
que ellos controlan tú el príncipe el
rey ahora Carlos recibía pues por
ejemplo aquí nosotros en España tenemos
una empresa muy potente cerámica Bueno
pues daba un donativo muy generoso a una
de esas
fundaciones que tenía el Rey Carlos y se
organizaban Pues en Saint James Pues un
evento y si pagabas más pues también
estaba el príncipe de gales allí en el
evento o sea que allí También gracias a
estos oropeles entra luego mucho dinero
No si haces esto el mundo
creo que la cifra de hoy es que
en el planeta alguien en algún momento
ha visto algo de este entierro Es que
llevamos 10 días es que ya no se puede
más con esta señora y Ya por fin la han
enterrado Entonces
yo creo que teniendo una guerra al menos
nosotros aquí en Europa muy cerca en
Ucrania con una inflación exagerada unos
problemas de que vamos a tener
energéticos un problema muy difícil con
Rusia y con china
a mí esto me sobrepasa 10 días 1 2 3 ya
me parece Porque además todo esto lo
tienen Bueno pues lo sacan a la calle y
es muy bonito y la gente se despide pero
creo que 10 este derroche está este
brillo brille y tanto oropel por la
calle con lo que tenemos encima a mí me
parece que es un poquito excesivo y es
un poquito pasa de acuerdo que la reina
lo ha dejado planificado así y el rey
nuevo Tiene que obedecer pero a lo mejor
se pueden poner de acuerdo y haberlo
hecho más reducido creo que
es excesivo porque no somos ricos no
vivimos en la abundancia y creo que hay
que mirar también un poquito a los demás
y a lo que está pasando a nuestro
alrededor antes de
mostrar tanta ostentación bueno
justamente eso quería agregar que por
supuesto Esto no es algo que se decidió
en un día sino que llevan años y años
planeándolo y nos lo han recalcado
muchísimo durante todos estos días es su
opinión es negativo
Sí para mí no no creo que sea excesivo
la trayectoria de Isabel segunda de 70
años lo merece y el pueblo británico lo
exige a ver es una exageración decir que
lo exige pero para mí la respuesta del
pueblo británico de casi medio millón de
personas pasando por su capilla ardiente
y ya lo dice todo con lo cual no me
parece excesivo toda la ceremonias que
se han realizado
el mayor gasto habrá sido el de
seguridad me sobrio porque el mayor
gasto será será ese pero enseguida
conoceremos las cifras de beneficios que
eso ha procurado a personas de la calle
a dueños de tiendas a propietarios de
hoteles
a taxistas a propiedades de restaurantes
de negocios de Todos Los visitantes que
han pasado por Londres durante todos
estos días y
en resumen todas las celebraciones de la
familia real británica que cuestan
muchísimo dinero al final son tan
rentables para el Reino Unido
también la parte de simbología y de y de
iconos de de
mundiales los necesitamos En mi opinión
como agua de mayo en estos momentos tan
tan dudosos en todo bueno justamente le
iba a decir que no en vano esa de la
monarquía del Reino Unido la monarquía
más famosa del mundo y donde se pueden
dar el lujo de decir que son queridos y
y que hay un altísimo respeto que no
existe en otras monarquías que Todavía
siguen en pie en otros países ya estamos
llegando hasta el cierre Así que
quisiera empezar a pedirle sus
conclusiones Carmen comienzo por ustedes
después de
de 10 días que estuvieron cargadísimos
de simbología porque no de opulencia
también Pero además de muchísima
ceremonia de muchísima honra y de
muchísimos recuerdos para la historia
Bueno qué va a pasar ahora con la
monarquía ustedes cómo lo ve
con la monarquía inglesa no tienen
difícil Bueno ya le están diciendo los
países de su mancomunidad de la
camonwell Pues ya están pidiendo que
bueno que con Isabel bien pero que
quieren independizarse Bueno pues ahí
tienen un problema fuera de sus
fronteras luego al haber hecho el brexit
con el resto de Europa pues se han
quedado un poquito solos sinceramente
están remando
solos hay en su Isla creo que que Carlos
III lo va a tener complicado no
imposible él no manda no legisla no hace
leyes o sea simplemente representa pues
pues nada larga vida al rey ha muerto la
reina viva el rey nada más que las
conclusiones son que que bueno Él ya
sabe lo que tiene en casa creo que va a
reducir la familia Más le vale porque
pues cuantos menos sean mejor lo
controlará y espero que su mujer que le
ha dado muchísimas muestras de cariño y
y de apoyarse en ella pues que la reina
antes de morirse en febrero le dijo que
deseaba que su pueblo la tomara como
reina consorte pues bueno ahí tendrá un
grandísimo apoyo hacia una historia de
amor preciosa la que han tenido ellos
dos ahora ya están en el trono y espero
que que tengan buena vida pero lo tienen
realmente complicado Bueno pues como el
resto de monarquías que aquí nadie está
exento de
problemas y lo digo por la nuestra que
también Nosotros hemos estado pendientes
de la situación de cómo se sentaban
nuestros cuatro Reyes bueno cada uno
Tiene lo suyo a ver cómo resuelven Cómo
se resuelve la cosa yo creo que cuando
todo va bien las cosas son más sencillas
pero es que ahora el mundo está
complicado Entonces ahora es cuando hay
que demostrar que uno es un buen
estratega
un buen Rey
una monarca que no tenía el destino de
gobernar que era muy joven Cuando llegó
al cargo y que finalmente lo ocupó por
nada más y nada menos que 70 años y
hechos importantes que marcó a lo largo
de toda su vida terminando a la segunda
era isabelina la monarquía perdurará por
favor dativo sus conclusiones esto
incluso Más allá de Carlos III
pues que no tiene una salud de hierro
estoy estoy de acuerdo con todo lo que
ha dicho Carmen lo tienen difícil pero
no imposible como las demás monarquías
europeas sobre todo la española que es
la que lo tiene más difícil pero no
imposible y esperemos que todo salga
como muchos deseamos y la monarquía
británica Pues a pesar de los problemas
del brexit que les ha dejado siendo una
isla
más de lo que lo es geográficamente el
tema de los países de la commonwealth
estoy seguro que Carlos continuará
siendo presidente de la commonwealth y
como he dicho en el principio los que
los países se quieren independizar y ya
lo son simplemente algunos países que no
quieren tener un rey extranjero o un rey
británico como jefe de estado son países
independientes y cada uno tiene su
política El Rey en esos países se
comporta igual que en la Gran Bretaña
pero seguirá siendo presidente de la
commonwealth Como así ya se ha dicho y
en el aspecto interior pues como ha
dicho Carmen difícil pero no imposible y
yo creo que lo tienen más fácil
que en otras monarquías que en España
por ejemplo y el el hecho de tener un
sucesor con una familia ideal y
Guillermo Catalina y sus hijos hace que
ese futuro sea muy esperanzador para la
casa para la familia y para los que
sienten cariño por la monarquía la
familia Guillermo Catalina y sus hijos
pues es como la gran esperanza del
futuro después de Carlos después de la
muerte de Carlos
Pues bien Se ha dicho todo lo que
podíamos decir hasta el momento ya
terminaron las ondas fúnebres de Isabel
II a nuestros invitados hoy Gracias por
estar con nosotros en el debate y a
nuestros televidentes Gracias por seguir
todas nuestras horas de programación de
especiales por este cambio de mando En
la jefatura de estado del Reino Unido
sigan con nosotros y nos vemos más
adelante en francés 24
[Música]